[Music]
on this Saturday night the calls for an
inquiry into the mass shooting you
cannot move forward in my opinion tell
you know the truth did police ignore the
warning signs as a killer stalked Nova
Scotia the first phase of getting back
to business in Canada the provinces will
have a lead role and the restrictions
that remain plus caring for care homes
should the feds take over from the
provinces and grooming your lofts in
this pandemic lockdown
[Music]
global national with Robin Gil
good evening and thank you for joining
us we begin with the investigation into
that mass killing in Nova Scotia it's
been one week since the lone gunman
began a 13 hour murder spree that
claimed the lives of 22 people police
believe many of the victims were
targeted while others were randomly
chosen their loved ones want answers and
question
whether a better warning system could
have saved lives
tonight the RCMP and the provinces
independent watchdog are investigating
but as Elizabeth McCaffrey reports there
are growing calls for a public inquiry
RCMP have provided a timeline of Nova
Scotia's mass shooting but so many
questions remain unanswered it's
complicated by the fact that the killer
isn't here to address them himself we
need to think about the extent to which
his motives can be delineated we need to
think about what warning signs that may
have been the pressure is on Nova
Scotia's premiere to launch a public
inquiry into Canada's worst mass
shooting I've asked the Attorney General
to look at what are the possibilities as
he works with his national partners an
inquiry could be ordered in-house by the
Nova Scotia government or the federal
government could order one as it did in
the 2014 shooting in Moncton New
Brunswick which left three RCMP officers
dead and two injured Warriors champion
Nova Scotia properly equipped trained
and supervised if not it's possible
there could be an investigation and
impossible charges it's just another
possibility
Rhonda McClellan who fears her friend
was killed in the spree says answers
would help her heal it's good to know so
you cannot move forward in my opinion
tell you know the truth the house of
Joanne Thomas and husband John's all was
set on fire during the shooting the
couple has not been heard from since
an inquiry can't technically assign
blame but it would make recommendations
and there will never be a trial for
Gabriel Wortman because he was killed
for now the investigation into this
horrific chapter in Nova Scotia's
history is in the hands of the provinces
police watchdog Elizabeth McCaffrey
Global News
Halifax to the Cova 19 crisis Prime
Minister Justin Trudeau has spoken with
provincial and territorial leaders about
plans for the eventual reopening of the
economy the two levels of government
have agreed to develop guidelines to
balance national coordination with
flexibility for provinces to move at
their own pace here's our chief
political correspondent David akin at
his daily press conference Saturday the
prime minister said he'll leave it to
the premiers to set the timeline for any
easing of kovat 19 restrictions the
provinces will have a lead role in
determining how their economies will
reopen what we are doing and some are
already moving on Thursday Saskatchewan
Premier Scott Moe announced his
provinces five phase plan to reopen he
was followed Friday by New Brunswick's
Blaine Higgs their plans will for
example allow golf courses to open this
spring provincial parks will also reopen
but in all cases social distancing rules
will remain in effect as will
restrictions on visiting seniors homes
next week Quebec Premier France while
ago and Ontario Premier Doug Ford will
outline their plans there's no one that
wants to open up the economy more than I
do and everyone else but we're gonna do
it responsibly we're gonna do it through
the guidance of our chief medical
officer of health unlike in the United
States where President Donald Trump has
clashed with state governors the
Premier's in the prime minister have
parked their partisan hats at the door
Canadians can you know take great
comfort in the fact that all of our
orders of government have been working
together in a very strong and aligned
way provinces will be expected to
demonstrate that before any reopening
there will be enough testing capacity
and enough resources to trace the source
of any new infections another emerging
issue making sure workers returning to
the job have enough protective gear like
shields and masks I don't think we
should be talking about reopening any
parts of the economy if we do not have a
strong plan to protect people working
there and prevent the spread of kovat 19
the Prime Minister also warned that
there is a great risk if a reopening
happens
too soon or if it is done poorly get it
wrong and that'll cost lives and could
set back a provinces recovery by months
Robin
David akin in Ottawa thinks David Canada
has turned to China to buy much-needed
personal protective equipment or PPE for
health care workers and the need is only
increasing but not all the equipment
coming in has been fit for use in an
interview with Mercedes Stevenson for
the West block the head of NATO says
member nations need to reconsider their
reliance on importing medical equipment
Mercedes Robin this Secretary General of
NATO is warning that countries like
Canada are too reliant on supply chains
that they don't control for critical
equipment like masks gloves and the
medical equipment used to treat Kovac 19
which are now coming primarily from
China in an interview with the West
block yen stolen Berg said that NATO
countries need to do more to make sure
they have adequate national stockpiles
when emergencies like the current
pandemic strike I think we as NATO
allies have to look into issues like
stocks do we have enough stocks to deal
with these kind of crises are we too
dependent on imports from countries
where they outside the alliance so one
of the lessons we have to learn some of
the homework we have to do after this
crisis is to look into yeah how to be
less dependent on imports of these kind
of essential equipment dealing with
these kind of health crises in recent
months stolen berg has warned that the
West must address a rising China which
he says has been steadily investing in
new military capabilities those concerns
have been exacerbated by the current
Kovan 19 crisis which has seen Canada
and other NATO countries scrambling to
buy masks and other desperately needed
equipment from China when their own
national stockpiles have fallen short a
significant amount of that equipment
that has been procured from China has in
fact been faulty tomorrow on the West
block the Secretary General will also
talk about the disinformation campaign
out there and how that's risking
spreading kovat 19 further as well as
whether Canada's defence spending will
take a hit as countries like Canada all
around the world
and especially those in NATO are plunged
into debt with kovat related spending
robbing Mercedes Stevenson in Ottawa
frontline workers who are helping fight
kovat 19 in Ontario are getting a raise
today premier Doug Ford announced the
province is thanking health care heroes
by providing a temporary financial boost
they will receive a $4 per hour
pandemic pay premium for every hour of
work they complete for the next 16 weeks
on top of that those who work over a
hundred hours per month will receive a
two hundred and fifty dollar bonus per
month for up to $1,000 over the next 16
weeks more than 350,000 people are
eligible for the pandemic premium that
includes those working in long-term care
homes emergency shelters supportive
housing correctional facilities as well
as community care providers and some
acute hospital staff bc's government is
going to relocate homeless people from
densely populated encampments in
Vancouver and Victoria to prevent the
spread of Cova 19 among the marginalized
populations the government issued a
public safety order for the camps to be
emptied by early May the people living
there will be relocated to empty hotels
and community centers in the two cities
the provinces Minister of Social
Development and poverty reduction warned
the camps are at high risk for Cova 19
outbreaks because of the lack of space
to practice physical distancing and
limited access to hygiene facilities
today Prime Minister Justin Trudeau
announced sixty two and a half million
dollars to support struggling seafood
and fish processors for weeks the
industry has been calling on the Liberal
government to cast a financial lifeline
to help with transportation costs
purchasing personal protective equipment
and to fund increased testing for
workers who are often based in remote
locations this funding will help ensure
that they can safely continue their
important work we're giving more money
to processors so that they can purchase
personal protective equipment for
workers adapt to health protocols and
support other social distancing measures
and here's a look at the Cova 19 picture
across Canada there are more than 45,000
confirmed cases in Canada but that is
just the number of people who have
tested positive for the illness not
everyone is tested more than 2500 people
have died the world is nearing another
grim milestone there are more than 2.9
million confirmed cases of kovat 19
globally and more than 200,000 people
have died Spain has the second highest
amount of Cova 19 cases in the world
with more than 220,000 and tonight the
UK has surpassed 20,000 deaths but the
country leading in cases is the United
States more than nine hundred and fifty
thousand Americans have tested positive
for the virus over 54,000 have died from
Kovan 19 despite the rise in cases and
deaths several US states are now easing
restrictions businesses are being
allowed to reopen but as Jennifer
Johnson explains many owners and
consumers are reluctant to leave their
homes state by state city by city a
chaotic reopening of businesses across
America the governor of Texas is
expected to issue as wide-ranging order
Monday but in Wichita Falls Texas
officials jump the gun reopening all
businesses Saturday morning still
requiring face masks and social
distancing this order is not forcing
businesses to open this is borders
allowing businesses to open after
Georgia started reopening several
businesses Friday
Savannah's mayor pushed back and says he
was threatened with racist emails a
common enemy is not each other it is
called : 90 Georgia and other states
ignoring federal guidelines which
require non-essential businesses to stay
closed until there is a decline in the
rate of Cova 19 infections for 14 days
Tony Roberts welcomed customers back to
his barbershop after six long weeks
somewhat reluctantly I was baffled at
the governor's announcement I'll be
honest the
they're still people dying and the
numbers are still going up US President
Donald Trump staying unusually quiet the
president is facing criticism after
comments about injecting disinfectants
into the body as treatment for cope in
nineteen New York's poison control
center says it had to manage 30 cases a
possible exposure to disinfectants after
the president's words at the White House
his economic adviser did talk with the
reporters sounding the alarm again about
America's growing unemployment rate I
think the president all of us are very
very concerned that we've got this
massive massive shock to the economy
that's completely unprecedented and it's
going to be a very heavy lift to get the
economy going again but studies show the
majority of Americans are still
reluctant to leave their homes and some
business owners are not taking any
chances
health experts continue to warn the rush
to reopen could have deadly consequences
Jennifer Johnson Global News Washington
coming up cutting off aid to conflict
zones in the middle of the Cova 19
crisis whenever I am going through
difficult times I ask God Almighty for
help cope it 19 hasn't stopped
celebrations for Ramadan but the Islamic
holy month does look a little different
instead of attending large gatherings at
mosques Muslims across Canada are
connecting online in what's being called
virtual Ramadan those observe this faith
are now fasting and reflecting and
sharing spiritual messages from the
safety of their homes for those living
in conflict zones in the Middle East
getting vital aid is even more difficult
in this pandemic just this week roads to
a Palestinian refugee camp in Lebanon
were cut off after cases of copán 19
were confirmed in the camp as crystal
commencing reports aid agencies fear the
youngest will suffer the most in
conflict zones eight agencies negotiate
and plead to get food medicine and basic
supplies to citizens the pandemic has
added another hurdle
you know it's placement Krampus sixty or
seventy thousand people living in and
highly densely populated I don't know
what we would do if the virus actually
makes it to the car
a covet nineteen related death was
recently reported in Northeast Syria
with a ten year long war the country is
isolated so that might provide some
protection in terms of imported cases
but there's also a lack of testing the
World Health Organization has Syria with
roughly forty cases surrounding
countries have hundreds or thousands
they think I don't know what to do with
kool-aid like I cannot escape even
fearing the virus refugees who risk
their lives to make it out are turning
around choosing instead to shelter in
their old often destroyed homes Save the
Children continues to work in Syria it
stopped bringing kids together for
school instead using online and radio
but that is a challenge in a war zone
many aid agencies are sounding the alarm
the Middle East for UNICEF was already
the place where 50% of our global
humanitarian action was taking place we
have twenty five million children and
the region in need of humanitarian
assistance so there was already a
vulnerability and now Cova nineteen
comes on top of that in Yemen there are
concerns over a five year long war
despite efforts to end the conflict in
order to fight kovat 19 a ceasefire has
been extended by one month according to
Saudi state TV
however it's not known if Houthi
fighters will accept it there are fears
about what will happen if the virus
spreads to the battered country UNICEF
is appealing for ninety two million
dollars to address the pandemic virus in
Syria Yemen Iraq and Sudan these people
have nobody else children the experts
say are the ones who suffer the most and
they have already endured too much
crystal de Manson Global News London
still have the Canadians keeping canines
happy until they can fly home to
Canadians in st. Lucia are staying on
the island during this crisis caring for
dozens of rescue animals abigail Beeman
introduces us to help pause and some of
their Kovan 19 challenges these eight
puppies aren't supposed to be at the st.
Lucia rescue anymore booked on Air
Canada flights to adoptive families in
Canada at the end of March those flights
canceled at the last minute four of the
dogs already kenneled and at the airport
the Canadians who run help paws told to
come back and pick them up their hearts
are open bringing this dog in and
sadness it's not coming home so for us
it's pretty devastating not only the
work that gets involved but now there's
puppies in a shelter for that much
longer normally they fly dogs to Canada
weekly now there's about 50 animals at
the rescue being able to fly dogs home
we're not able to bear any more dogs and
that's leaving much more animals in the
streets that could be in our care and
it's obviously super stressful for us
because we want so badly to help animals
but we we can't work we're two people
and we don't have you know the resources
all of our money is now going to be
having to go into our flight they've had
some issues getting food face medication
shortages rising costs and fewer people
to help whenever the dogs can leave it
may cost three times as much airlines
charge by weight we're hoping would give
us the same cost that we would have paid
and they're asking for a refund for
their paperwork Air Canada hasn't
offered anything nor did it respond to
Global News questions by deadline in
Ottawa Nick Pula and his partner wait
patiently for their dog Jane to arrive
it hoped that we were sort of prepared
at least a little bit for this um this
sort of uncertainty waiting game it's
difficult but we know that the animals
aren't good
and so that that helps they get lots of
photos of Jane as they wait amid their
challenges rising costs and anxiety help
pause uses it social media to spread
smiles
Gordo did what we know there's so many
things around the world everyone's that
stressed out as possible so we don't
really want to show as much of the
stress that we go through so we do try
now to show a little more positivity and
just light-hearted post keeping the dogs
happy these Canadians aren't going
anywhere
making sure the pups stay safe during
the struggle
Abigail Beeman global news Ottawa up
next sheer madness and stay-at-home
haircuts as we all adjust to this new
normal that includes getting used to
life with no hair salons or barber shops
while some have the chops to cut hair
others are having a tough time mike
gelée looks at the great lengths some
will go for a fresh look during this
pandemic it's been so long since I've
had a haircut all this seems foreign to
me paint brushes in foil
whatever happened to scissors so I was
asked to do a story on coping 19
haircuts nice great so I looked to my
friend Roy he was given his daughter
here he knows what he's doing
he's got a nice hair he's no longer a
friend so why don't we get to watch some
hatchet jobs together shall we
for me this guy is everything he's
terrified either of his wife or the
haircutter both and it makes me happy
but far too much of what I found online
made me ask why does this guy really
need a haircut and why is this man who
looks salon fresh allowing his wife to
give him a trim and there it is it's
probably the wine then there's this
video I was openly rooting for a
disaster and it's only partly because he
can't pronounce lithium ion no it's not
and that's good I expected more of the
same until I found this guy and I have
to say he's my hero the man after all
is using shears shears and he does a
pretty good job
there's no vanity here just purpose and
I was at peace with it all Who am I
kidding
fear of clippers is far more interesting
get cut in Canada lycra leg level use
Toronto and that is global national for
this Saturday I'm Robin Gill
tonight we leave you with some of
Canada's top dancers bringing the ballet
to you lacking space but not passion the
National Ballet of Canada is still
dancing albeit in isolation thank you
for watching and we'll see you back here
tomorrow good night
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]